hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game that was played today between
the world chess champion Magnus Carlsen
and a professional soccer player Arnold
logs and earth Trent who is a write-back
defender for a Liverpool and although
some of you say that I shouldn't say
soccer I should say football but it's
really the same thing I don't know my
favorite video game regarding this sport
was I believe it was called a ISS
international superstar soccer Pro
Evolution which was later renamed into
p/es Pro Evolution Soccer so I don't
know I last time I mentioned this you
were like really really upset that I
said soccer instead of football but
that's really not to the point here so
getting back to this match thank you
everyone for trying to help me find the
moves it really took me an entire day
finally here a good sir mark halls be
tagged me on twitter where Eugene
Kaspersky himself posted the moves of
this game as the this match was
organized by Kaspersky Labs and it's
very interesting as you can see here on
the photo right there you have Trent and
Magnus Trent is being aided by some sort
of eye tracking software now as how I
understood it as they really didn't
specify anything about this there is
this software that uses cameras that
track Carlson's eye movements and it
should help trend here to show what
which moves Coulson is considering so it
would help him make his moves now of
course he does need all the help he can
get against the world champion but after
you see this see this game I think that
it will be exactly this that prevented
him from playing normal chess and it
really it was really a weird game to put
it mildly you know when you remember a
couple of months back where I went that
obsessive learner max Deutsch I
challenged Magnus cos and it was a you
know compared to this it was actually an
impressive game and I think it's it's
the Kaspersky Lab software had to blame
for for trends play in this game but
you'll see what I mean by that so Kay
Carson has the white pieces and he opens
with E 4 we have d6 the pair's defense
b4 and the knight to f6 so all is well
for now I'm just okay and here across
and proceed simply Knight to c3 defenses
EP for pawn and now black has a whole
variety of options he can go east 6e v
h6 he can go night b b7 to give more
protection to d5 square but for some
reason Bishop to d7 was played here now
I don't think this is a move anyone who
who plays chess would make as it's
really a weird move to make so I think
that if anything that's software that
was supposed to help treinta was
actually responsible for a move like
this but okay it's not the end of the
world cousin simply pushes the pawn to
e5 we have E 5 and now not capturing but
rather going back with the knight nice
the g8 and while Knights back is often a
very strong move here it's a it's not a
bad move because even if you capture
capture in the century you would still
have to move the knight back across and
pushes f4 and here we have Bishop to e6
another weird move with East 6 or
perhaps even Knight to h6 as f4 has been
played no Bishop captures Knight can be
played it would actually be a decent
move controlling f5 in g4 but okay we
have Bishop to e6 again playing twice
with the same piece so not really not
really something you want to do across
and simply continues developing we have
Knight to f3 g 6 and now d5 forcing the
bishop to move even further back and
here we have yet another weird move here
instead of something like Bishop to d7
or Bishop to a5 we actually have b6 so I
don't know what this software was a
telling trend but it wasn't telling him
to move the bishop as the bishop is
being attacked on e6 so ok cousin
captures the bishop D captures an e6 we
have F captures on e6 and now comes
knife to g5 simply what idea of
capturing on e6 and also after the move
that was played in the game it wins the
rook by force
translate the D captures on e5 we have
Queen captures King captures and now of
course Knight to f7 check for king the
King ended the rook
we have came to d7 Knight captures rook
we have Bishop to g7 attacking crosses
night and the night goes back to f7 here
King goes back to c8 perhaps looking for
some sanctuary on b7 and cousin goes to
Bishop to c4 and eyes developing move
also eyeing that pawn on e6 so here King
back to d7 so first king to see it now
King back to d7 of course as this pond
was under attack and there was no other
way to defend it cousin goes right back
to g5 now with a double attack against
the e6 pawn and knife to c6 now trying
to begins developing his pieces we have
Bishop captures on e6 this comes with
check King to d8 would give him black
some more opportunities to fight but
here translate King to d6 and now I
really don't know how this software was
aiding him in any way but feel free to
pause the video here and try to find the
winning move for white I'll give you a
couple of seconds if you want to decide
whether to do it or not for those of you
who were able to do it congratulations
you have just found a mate in one
and for those who just want to enjoy the
show it's actually nice to e4 that this
comes with check and also the knife from
e4 covers the c5 square the bishop is
guarded by the knight here and there is
nowhere to go but up is covering these
squares and the King is completely
locked in so Knight C to e for this is
checkmate by Carson and a very nice 17
move game a lot of people are saying
that it took him almost twice as much as
it took us and to defeat Bill Gates if
you remember that game I don't have it
on my channel but you can just google it
you will immediately find it now but
it's it's really not important in how
many moves you beat someone because
someone can you know just keep the game
going without any any actual chance of
winning the game just to make the game
last longer so that's what I really not
something that matters about people I've
seen on Twitter and Facebook really
enjoy pointing this out but yeah that's
pretty much the game and I was very much
looking forward to this because as the
game was announced
although social media networks and the
trend to announce that Carson announced
that Magnus company Magnus play
announced it so play Magnus and I said
so I was really happy to see what this
game would be like and I wrong I was
kind of expecting more and I think the
game would be much better if trying to
just played on his own without being
aided by the by this this eye tracking
software but I don't know I guess we'll
never know now you know watching this
game really
max max dodge game really seems seems
like something now if you haven't
checked out the Magnus Carlsen vs. max
Dutch video I will also put a link to it
in the description below and a lot of
interesting links about this whole event
so feel free to check it out I would
like to thank Tyler Alonso Martin Paul
Britt
Juergen Paul Bako David Monty and
Citarum ear for contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos your thing called for
watching and I'll see you soon
hopefully with another interesting video
and we're going back to the Bobby
Fischer story thank you all and I'll see
you soon